the Joe Rogan experience one thing he
has done those the what I mean I'm it's
gonna sound ridiculous but when he has
Kim Kardashian bringing cases of people
that were unjustly prosecuted or
unjustly imprisoned and he releases them
a guy like that I like that she does it
and I like that he does it takes a lot
for me to get angry but when people were
clowning them and I'm like Kim
Kardashian you can say a lot of [ __ ]
about her
she saved people's lives she's helping
people in a tremendous way you're gonna
tell those families that Kim Kardashian
[ __ ] you she's helped 17 people be
released from prison in the last three
months and I think it's also very
disturbing how glib a lot of people are
about prison yeah and it's a really I
don't know what it's like and I don't
want to know what it's like don't worry
it's no joke yeah so but it is a
punchline and it's like you're laughing
about people being traumatized for life
and possibly having no possibility of
returning it to society if this is
people used to be able to laugh about
stuff like that cuz it would be like
laughing at it at work you know you go
to work and you're like hey OJ's in the
can he's gonna take it in the cab you
would go to work and you'd say something
stupid like that and it wouldn't go
anywhere but when you say something like
that on Twitter or Facebook like ooh boy